[Musique]
la commune de cilaos fait partie des
centres bourgs retenus au niveau
national dans le cadre de l'appel à
projets sur la revitalisation de ces
territoires dans le cadre de l'appel à
projets on a identifié trois axes donc
un désastre concerne tout ce qui est le
secteur économies développées
consolider l'activité économique sur le
territoire si l'os un autre axe ça va
être deux
développer si la hausse autour de sa
singularité et dernier élément dernier
axe qu'on a retenu c'était de relier ce
que la hausse reste du territoire donc
au reste de la silice donc
permettant de réaménager aussi la rn5
est la seule voie d'accès a ainsi l'os
la commune dispose désormais d'une
maison de projet avec une équipe dont
les missions seront d'élaborer cette
stratégie de revitalisation ainsi que de
proposer des actions cohérentes aux
spécificités de cilaos
ça va se traduire par la création des
aires de loisirs sur le territoire de
cilaos la création d'une maison de la
lentille
[Musique]
réalisation de la piétonnisation de la
rue du père boiteau n'y actuellement en
train d'élaborer un schéma piétons sur
le site afin sur le centre bourg dans ce
schéma piétons consiste à créer des
circuits touristiques à l'intérieur du
centre bourg autour de différentes
thématiques donc des thématiques qui ont
été retenus donc ça va être les produits
du terroir l'eau les personnages
importants de cilaos qui sont
matérialisés par des rues que ça ça
constitue aussi un circuit thématique et
on va expliquer l'histoire de l'histoire
de ces personnages quelle a été leur
rôle pour aussi la hausse la commune a
également signé avec le département de
la réunion une convention d'opérations
de revitalisation du centre bourg et de
développement du territoire
cette convention équivaut à la mise en
oeuvre d'une opération d'amélioration de
l'habitat qui s'étend sur 6 ans nous
avons nous à la ville de cilaos
accueilli avec beaucoup de plaisir donc
le partenariat avec le département qui
nous soutient à hauteur de deux millions
cinq cent sur les cinq ans à venir
quand on améliore l'habitat des gens on
améliore aussi leur cadre de vie et
c'est vrai qu'à cilaos nous avons une
ville qui se dévitalise de plus en plus
alors si nous avons ce partenariat avec
le département c'est pour aussi aider la
ville de cilaos à maintenir la
population sur le centre ville centre
bourg et pour pouvoir leur donner une
maison décente et c'est vrai comme nous
dit notre cher présidente
avoir une maison aujourd'hui avoir une
maison confortable qui correspond à nos
besoins c'est aussi très important pour
le mieux vivre de chacun d'entre nous le
département de la réunion au regard de
sa politique volontariste qu'elle mène
en direction des publics les plus
fragiles et les plus défavorisés autour
de l'habitat financera par an 40 projets
d'amélioration légère et 10 projets
d'amélioration lourde
[Musique]